And now to you, Scoutmaster.
Hey folks, we're going to try something a little new this week.
We're going to have a little trivia contest. okay,
The way to win is to go to the Scoutmaster blog Facebook page and post your correct answer
on that page.
First person that does that wins the contest and they're going to receive a copy of Mark
raise, the Scoutmasters other handbook, which is a really helpful guide with a lot
of information in it that you don't find in the- you know, quote unquote- real
Scoutmasters handbook.
So I'm going to send you a brand new copy of that if you are the first
person to post the correct answer to the question on the Scoutmaster blog
Facebook page.
So don't send me an email,
Don't go to scoutmastercgcom and go through the contact thing or
anything like that.
The only way to enter is to go to the Scoutmaster blog Facebook page.
Okay, we got that straight.
So the question is this: the World Organization of the Scouting Movement
conducted a census in 2010, and they concluded there are, in round
numbers, about 25 million Scouts in 161 countries who have an internationally
recognized Scout organization.
So the question is: which country of those 161 has the most Scouts in
their National Scouting Organization? post your answer on the Scoutmaster
blog Facebook page and the first correct answer wins the book.
Okay, so this should be fun.
We'll see how it works.
Hey, this is podcast number 143..
So welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green and I'm broadcasting to you straight from the
middle of Hurricane Sandy, and I know a lot of you are right
there with me.
Yeah, it's a pretty big storm.
You may have heard of it
If you turned on the TV or a radio or went outside your house
in the past few days. but hey, we're weathering it just fine.
but you may hear a little background noise because it's
pretty windy out there.
So let's take a look in the mailbag. this time
Paul Kemp is a Scoutmaster of Troop 720 and he wrote in
to say very succinctly:
Thank you for maintaining this resource.
Well, thank you, Paul, for being in touch.
Certainly do appreciate it.
Ray Britton is the Scoutmaster of Troop 42 in Oak Ridge, Tennessee,
and he wrote in about podcast 142, our last podcast, and our
talk about youth leadership development. and Ray had this
to say: is that once again, you hit the proverbial nail
on the head.
I think your description of leadership development as opposed
to leadership training is a much better way to think about
turning Scouts into leaders.
Teenage boys just don't learn the way adults do.
My experience is that Scouts understand intellectually how
to lead.
If you ask them about a situation, they can tell you a
pretty good way to handle it. but let them experience
the situation on a camp out and they may not execute
what they know.
Slowly but surely, though, as they experience things,
it starts to sink in
Me. I feel like I'm in the movie Groundhog Day.
Every year you get the first year Scouts just starting
to function as Boy Scouts, and the youth leaders are just
starting to get it, and here comes a new batch of first
year Scouts and then a new batch of leaders, and it
happens over and over again and it does.
Yep, that's the way it works, Ray.
We wake up in a new world every day.
Things are always happening, and thanks for being in
touch from down in Oak Ridge.
Dan Jones wrote in to say I discovered your blog today
and I love it.
I had a chance to listen to about half of your recent
podcast and it's very good.
I found a few small problems with your archive page
that you may want to look into.
Dan goes on to describe some misplaced links and things
like that, and I really do appreciate that.
If you find something wrong, get in touch with me,
because we are a team of one here.
I'm not a big proofreader. sometimes, and you know,
after you put 143 links on a page, some days
something is going to be messed up somewhere.
So I really appreciate it.
When you see things, you do get in touch.
Dan goes on to say thanks for all your hard work on
the project.
I'm looking forward to spending some time here
and we're looking forward to having you along
with us.
Thanks for touching base and thanks for letting
me know about the stuff on the archive page
that needed to be fixed there.
Last night I had the pleasure of participating
in a Google Plus Hangout- my first Hangout, at
least on Google Plus- and it was great.
Arlen Ward, who's a scouter out there in Colorado,
hosted it and the subject was talking about
starting Boy Scout troops and there was a good,
lively discussion, a lot of good participants,
and maybe ScoutmasterCG will host a Hangout or
two.
If you'd be interested in something like that,
email me at scoutmastercg at Verizonnet and
let me know what you'd be interested in discussing.
It's a great way to get some good ideas.
It's fun to talk with other scouts and we can
do that from all over the country and all
over the world.
Now, on this edition of the Scoutmaster
podcast in Scoutmastership, in seven minutes or less,
we have our second installment of youth leader
development, and then I've got a couple of emails to
answer and that should be enough for this podcast,
Don't you think?
Well, I do,
So, let's get started.
Shall we scout master ship in seven minutes or less.
In the first installment in this series on youth
leader development, we discussed some key concepts
about the relationship between scouts and leadership
positions and the way that they develop as leaders.
We're going to talk about what we can do as adult
volunteers to help foment this kind of youth
leadership development.
Event based training- the National Youth Leader
Training like NYLT- and troop based training present
both some experiential and some classroom
learning. as good as the event style training can
be, though, it's only part of a broader developmental
process.
If the conditions in a scouts home troop aren't focused
on continual leadership development, the benefits
of training scouts by sending them to these big
events is going to be kind of minimal.
So what are kind of the ideal conditions in a troop
for continual leadership development.
I say the single greatest key to strong youth
development is the attitude and actions of adults
associated with the troop.
If they're not invested in creating the conditions
required for continuing youth leader development,
things will progress very slowly if at all.
There's a basic paradox to face here.
Youth leader development in its earliest stages
will not look like development at all.
In fact it will look like things are moving
backwards.
Getting past that stage requires an exceptional
quality in adults and that exceptional quality
I borrow from the National Outdoor Leadership School
in a leadership quality
They identify as capacity for adversity and uncertainty.
I'm going to say that again:
Capacity for adversity and uncertainty. scouts
developing as leaders won't perform at the same
level as adults. in the first stages of development
Their performance may even be hard to detect, let
alone evaluate. when things go undone or mistakes
are made, adults tend to step in
And, as we noted in our first installment, adults
can grow so discouraged with this whole process
They give up the idea on developing scouts into
leaders in any real, substantive way.
Scouts in their families also need some capacity
for uncertainty. as we are developing youth leaders,
Families especially need an initial introduction
and continual reinforcement that youth leaders
are at the helm and that they are developing
leaders, not seasoned professionals.
Many families initial experience scouting through
a cub pack and they've probably developed really
high expectations for order and communication
and consistency. and the chaos, incomplete communication
and the inconsistency of developing youth leaders
can be a real big challenge for them.
It's right for the adult volunteers in a troop
to communicate directly with parents through some
kind of parallel channel as the youth leaders
communicate with scouts.
They need to balance the effort to create a capacity
in their youth leaders to communicate detail
plans with effective communication to families.
These are two different things.
Scouts are going to be contacting and talking
to scouts and the adult volunteers in the troop
are going to back this up with this kind of
parallel communication with scouts families.
We don't necessarily have to repeat everything
that is said.
We don't necessarily have to add to the things
that were said, but we need to let our scouting
families know that we're right there when they
have questions, that we know what's going on
and that we will help them get answers and will help
kind of level out that inconsistency of communication
that comes from youth leaders very often
as they're developing in some ways. adult
volunteers are going to serve as a buffer
between families and youth leaders.
So, as a buffer, what we do is protect the
developmental environment. for youth leaders to
develop, they have to have this safe environment
that's free from a lot of coercion, a lot of
pressure to to begin to learn and develop
as as leaders. and I would liken it to a vegetable
garden.
You know your vegetable garden needs protection
from pests, just as developing youth leaders
need protection from outside influences
that are going to disrupt the process. as they
develop, they're going to become more confident
in addressing the concerns of adults and they
will begin to stand up for themselves.
But until they have this confidence, they need
to be protected, just like a little seedling
in the garden needs to be protected. we've got
to look out for the scouts. many things that
are detrimental to this developmental environment
are minimized if we maintain balanced
relationships between youth leaders and
their adult counterparts. now that balanced
relationship is not necessarily constant
oversight, advice and over instruction,
because that tends to stifle the discovery
crucial to leadership development. adults
working with youth leaders need to use
a minimal amount of telling, communication
or direct instructions.
They should also understand that youth
leaders have different levels of tolerance
for mentoring and advising. too little
mentoring and advising and oversight and
advice is almost always better than too
much. our role is more reflective than
directive. there's an important difference
there. our role is more reflective than
directive, where we are available but not
intrusive. when we balance this relationship,
we create a safe environment for
experiential development. now, given a goal
or a task, youth leaders will seek a solution.
if their proposed approach is not dangerous
or inappropriate, they should be allowed
to make it happen, and this is important,
even if we're confident that that approach
may not work. the process of trial and
error leads to discovery. and think
about Edison. Edison tried out a lot of
materials before he discovered which
worked well for a light bulb filament.
he developed the light bulb experientially.
now, the difference between Edison and our
developing youth leaders is: Edison was
looking for an unknown. our youth leaders
are discovering something that we probably
already know how to do. if we tell them
everything we know, we deny them the more
powerful and more lasting experience of
discovering it for themselves. if we
tell them what we know, if we say, hey,
you know what I have the answer to this,
let me tell you what it is- they don't get
to discover what that answer is. that's
the difference between what I call the
directive approach and the reflective
approach. in the third installment of this
series will be in podcast number 144,
we'll discuss some specific practices
that aid reflective development of
leadership,
Boy Scouts,
Boy Scouts.
Hi, this is Dr Paul Auerbach and you are
listening to Clark Green on the Scoutmaster
podcast
Email. that is folks, and here's an answer
to one of your emails.
I'm going to tell you how to be in touch
with your comments and questions in just
a moment, but I've got email here to take
a look at when will remain anonymous.
describes a bit of a difficult situation,
and the author says this. he says we are
a new troop and I'm a new scoutmaster.
I'm having a problem with one of our
adults yelling at the Scouts.
he's a strong-willed man and he takes
any behavior he does not like as
disrespect. I've refused to be a troop
where adults yell at Scouts or make them
feel belittled or threatened. I am
afraid of this guy, though, and how we
react if I confront him about this
now. this is a really serious matter,
and it's not going to necessarily be
handled by the Scoutmaster. it's going
to be handled by the committee chair
and the chartered organization representative.
most of you have probably heard me say
before, but the we need to brush up a
little bit on our job descriptions
every once in a while. so the
committee chair and the chartered
organization representative are the ones
who select volunteers and they have
the authority to remove volunteers.
I have no idea if the person in
question here can be counseled
out of their bad behavior or not and
frankly, it's none of my business and
it's really none of the business of the
Scoutmaster either. the simple fact
is is that this kind of behavior-
yelling at Scouts and
threatening them or belittling
them- has to stop now,
not later. it needs to stop
right away. the writer
notes that they don't like
confrontation and they're even a bit
scared of this guy. a
confrontation doesn't have to be angry
or have other negative feelings
associated with it, but this kind of behavior
has to be confronted. like I said
before, I don't see this
as being something for the Scoutmaster
to do, because the Scoutmaster
does not. the Scoutmaster does not
select and approve volunteers.
that is up to the committee chair
and the chartered organization representative.
so what we're going to do here is we're going to go
to them and we're going to tell them what's going on.
they may need to be reminded about
their job description a little bit,
but here's the shorthand. the committee chair
and the chartered organization representative
collaborate with the head of the chartered organization
to select and approve adult
volunteers. they have absolute
authority as to who may
and may not serve and their
decisions cannot be appealed
to a higher level. in other words,
nobody can go to the district or the council
or whatever and say: these guys over here
in this troop are treating me unfairly,
they remove me from membership
and I want to be reinstated. that's not going to
happen because the
chartered organization owns the unit
and it's their decision about
who gets to serve as a volunteer in that
unit. so volunteers serve at the
pleasure of the chartered organization. they can be
removed at any time, for cause or for no cause
at all. no vote
of the committee, approval of the
district or council or even the scout master
is required for any of these decisions.
committee chair and the chartered
organization representative have complete
authority. and if they get flummoxed
and they're in a tie and they're not
able to decide, well, the head of the
chartered organization makes the final
decision. so now that we know
what the scope of authority is here about
decision making once they're
appraised of the situation of
the scout leader who's yelling at scouts.
they go, meet with them and tell
them that this is a serious matter
and it must not continue.
depending on the individual and depending
on the reaction, they may need to be able to
council and discuss things and figure things out,
but they may need to just
tell that. tell this person that their
services are no longer required
and that they are terminating any
relationship he has with the unit.
as of now, and before they go
into a meeting like this, they will
have prepared a letter to this effect
and handed to the leader in question
and after that, that's it,
they're out. there's no appeal,
there's nothing else that needs to be done.
that's it it. why
is the situation where an adult is
yelling and intimidating and
perhaps belittling scouts
a serious situation?
because it's called bullying
and it can't continue.
we just don't do that in scouts.
now, I understand
how uncomfortable and difficult this kind of
situation is, but imagine this,
and this is a little bit of a silly illustration.
but imagine you're out camping and a bear
is about to attack your scouts and you have a rifle.
what are you going to do
now? as much as you may regret it,
you're going to shoot the bear.
you're not going to reason with the bear.
you're not going to tell the scouts just to ignore the bear
because he's in a bad mood and he'll go away.
or you're not going to
allow the bear to attack one of your scouts
and drag them off.
you're going to shoot the bear.
so how is the situation
with this adult volunteer yelling at scouts
all that much different
and how is your reaction
going to be all that much different?
this is a real thing that hurts
scouts and hurts units
and it has to be dealt with.
and it has to be dealt with quickly
and it has to be taken care of.
and the last bit of advice I have for you
happens via email.
emails are really problematic.
they can get interpreted in all kinds of different ways.
you have to meet face to face
when you're dealing with issues like this.
after I received this question
and sent a reply,
I got this message back
that pointed out how things were resolved.
the yeller came by my house
and apologized for his actions the night before.
he said he would apologize to the scouts
as a group and individually.
I explained to him
we have a yell free troop.
our committee chair is going to talk to him
about it as well.
he's going to make it clear that if he cannot refrain from this behavior,
his services as a leader will no longer be needed.
thanks for your email advice.
we have a lot to learn. as we're a young troop,
we want to help our scouts create a great program.
I had fallen short of calling this bullying,
but it's exactly what it is
and I'm glad you made that clear for me.
if it happens again, I'm not going to be afraid to stop it immediately.
thanks for all you do for us
and once again
I'm withholding the name and the location there.
I'm relieved to hear
that this came to a good resolution
and that this volunteer saw the error of his ways
and saw it
was appropriate to apologize.
plus, the unit has also got a bit of a backbone now,
in that the committee chair is going to address this
and just make sure it's understood by everyone,
and now the scout master
has this bit of experience where they can say:
I didn't really recognize this
for what it is. thank you for pointing out,
and I will not hesitate to stop it in the future.
so good outcome all around on that one,
if you want to email me with a question
that we can help you with here on the podcast.
we'll find out how to do that in just a minute.
well, thanks so much for listening.
now here's how you can keep in touch:
read the scout master blog at
scoutmastercgcom,
and when you get to scoutmastercgcom,
you'll see that you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
you can subscribe to this podcast,
the scout master podcast, on iTunes,
and when you do, please feel free to leave a comment
to review or a rating.
you can also access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you can get details about how to do that
at stitchercom.
you can call in and record a shout out
to be included in a future edition
of the scout master podcast by going to
scoutmastercgcom
and following the shout out link.
you can experience the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
that's right. you can follow us at
scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
hey, get over there. leave your correct answer
for the trivia question we mentioned at the beginning
of the podcast today.
you can tweet scoutmastercg on Twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive scoutmastercg
circle, search for scoutmastercg
on Google plus.
if none of that works, you can email me,
Clark Green, with your comments and questions
at scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast are not official
publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and before we go, let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
my thank you, sir,
until next time
you.